look there's no easy way to say this
seven more Blockbusters just closed
you're officially the last one on earth
I don't love the pattern that's starting
to emerge hello
I'm supposed to be the next Tarantino if
I don't work in a video store uh-huh
yeah that's what's holding you back no
one's going anywhere because everything
is under control
that's reassuring
just like one of your favorite bosses
from a movie like boss baby or Devil's
Advocate one of those is a baby and one
is Satan and look at the heights they
reach despite their circumstances Fair
continue this Focus I think we're gonna
be okay an eviction notice I feel real
bad about it that's why I drew a sad
face on it
no one takes me seriously I've been
working here since the seventh grade
that is not the flex you think it is
I've always thought of myself as over 40
at heart I don't get why you're getting
a degree in accounting all you do is
talk about making movies accounting is
basically like the film of numbers see
that was the saddest thing I've ever
said saddest thing I've ever said is one
ticket for Space Jam two sorry if I
haven't seen stoked to be suddenly
working the same job I have in high
school just so I can afford the studio
apartment I had to rent because I caught
my husband Aaron on a date with a 25
year old also named Aaron why is that
worse I don't know but it is
everything I had into this store
because it's the only place that's ever
felt like home
cluster three
just so you know I am aware of your
feelings towards Eliza
I mean are you like picking up a Vibe or
something love
so fun
this calls for another drink
you're a business owner you did the
Whole 30 twice and you smell good Timmy
you are in your Prime right now okay
what makes it like living such a Dream
well you know it has it's up to that
it's sarcasm she almost got you come on
man
whatever happened here
they want to hide it
they can't hide it from me
who are you Rachel
what'd you see
we should not have come to Metropolis
the Temple of azeratus now yours
welcome to the ancient world Mr Luther
soon the gods will know your name
the gods already know me
oh
come on Lex Luthor
I'd like to meet in person
who got caught up in the occult he's the
only man Bruce Wayne was ever afraid of
Superman's not afraid of him neither am
I you should be we're dealing with the
supernatural that scares me my name is
jinx and this is the person we're going
to for help good Magic versus bad man
Dick Grayson deal maker extraordinaire
hard pass okay I don't know whatever all
this is but we do need your help
the world is a brutal place we're all so
alone what are you doing
who the hell are you it's just a hunch
but I'm gonna assume she's a bad guy
ever since we got to Metropolis strange
things have been happening to me I'm
gonna try and tell me something I can
hear everything that people here say
about me they will never let me forget
what I am
my father likes one you're a part of our
family and if you leave it's gonna hurt
us
foreign
[Music]
dead for five and a half years
aren't you see
curing things in your head you have some
kind of expiration patient second 2024
thank you
I had a Colleen it was awful
everything was swallowed by Ash
destruction
[Music]
it's
where it wasn't an accident
we're supposed to save the passengers
together
our death date is in 18 months we have
to follow every lead
we're missing something
two years ago I touched the tail fin and
disappeared again and then came back
five years older
I need to remember what happened
what is it it's not just a box
it's the Black Box
another passenger was murdered I think
they just kill yourself
have we had this wrong the whole time
you didn't fly into the storm it flew
into US
it shows us
a direct link to Divine consciousness
whatever happens
we'll get through it together
[Music]
we are now beginning our final descent
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
whether we like it or not
turn your heads to the sky
it took a long time for this place to
find its footing
and I took a very personal risk bringing
you here Ali
please don't make me regret that choice
you don't want to stay here with me
I just want to keep everyone safe
thinking you've got all the answers
[Music]
people don't change alley they just
reveal themselves over time
[Music]
we need to leave what's wrong it's
something we can never come back from
well that's gonna be a problem
Washington D.C Margo
why would I want to help you
can see if you do
I'll give you what you want
[Music]
in light of the events of the last 12
months
perhaps I have more to reflect on than
most
[Music]
the royal family is in genuine crisis
[Music]
have Royal scandals damaged the
country's reputation House of Windsor
should be binding the nation together
setting an example of idealized family
life
it's a situation that cannot help would
affect the stability of the country
for years I've called for a more modern
monarchy that reflects the world outside
I don't think it's my behavior the
threatening its survival you as Future
King have a duty
never understand how it's really been
for me
[Music]
I never stood a chance
she's a breaking point because of the
way she feels she's been treated they
see her as a threat
remember the one condition the one rule
you're a man loyal to this family
you're inside it yes it's a system A
Better or For Worse we're all stuck in
him
feels it's all about to erupt
she opens her mouth and hand grenades
come out she wants to tear down the
temple let's go for it
I won't go quietly I'll battle till the
end
You Belong To The Past
and the world will move on
and we'll be left with nothing
[Music]
how did it come to this
[Music]
[Music]
this job it would be easy to lose faith
in humanity
it would be a mistake
[Music]
this is my son Vincent he's missing
we all have an unconscious self feelings
sometimes serve me
I'd like to partner with Avi
I want to learn how you do your job how
you think
you can't learn what he does
what is going on here sometimes people
without knowing them all I can suggest
at the moment is
I don't know my husband anymore
I found this tape to the window
I still got unsolved murders we're gonna
put three detectives on a bomb scare
they're related something's missing you
feel it are you a good detective
I go to sleep with Vincent in my head
and I wake up with him in the morning do
I need to take you off this case I'm
almost there
it's possible you know something about
the bomb he doesn't
you think your son is dead how dare you
ask me that
the longer a case goes on the more
intense you get she's concerned that
you're losing perspective
every single one of us at some point in
our life as a what do I do moment
this will be your moment
Gandhi Eleanor Roosevelt Nelson Mandela
Henry Ford these are leaders who trusted
their inner voice
oh you've got to be kidding me
[Music]
[Applause]
this is way better off without them damn
straight this is our masterpiece
he's doing well I know you guys didn't
think I could do it no no
I mean we literally haven't said your
name in a year oh I'd like to introduce
you to our newest employee I'm glad
you're back you know it's janitor I see
a lot of things but you have nothing to
worry about there's nothing like strange
or nefarious going on that's some
Illuminati and even if there was you'd
never know it um sorry wait what he's
always wanted to bring mq to Hollywood
but I'm the first one to pull it off how
could I not even be consultant on my DNA
is literally all over that game
gross
Joe mangionello No One's Gonna believe
that he could play me he's not big
enough he's like six four six five six
five
you have made a huge mistake I am
Elizabeth Graham one's building an
entire game from scratch and you're
pacing around to metaphors
I totally get it I had to work with
those wackos too
[Laughter]
oh cray cray banana
really
posted notes are a part of my system
wait can you just be a normal person and
just take notes on your phone because
like a normal person I lost my phone
ages ago and now Dana takes my calls for
me don't nobody call you
[Music]
I'll tell you a story
finds about revenge
can't help but think yours is too
[Music]
I've lived here my whole life
seen how I made hell
so long sergeant
do you remember
and there you've been one of us but out
here
you wanna
one of them not to fight
again
it was like magic
only this afternoon you were tied up
there I was lying down over there
both about to get killed and yet here we
are
and it's everyone else that's dead
someone kill my child but now I'm gonna
kill me
[Music]
will you help me
can you shoot I have to
oh you'll laugh dude
I'm not quite the one what I expected
you're everything I'd expect of a man
[Laughter]
this country
I sometimes wonder if there's Horror in
US
it kept my mouth shut for 25 years
I don't know what you're expecting now
that you're back I'm respecting adequate
compensation
Tulsa what's Tulsa I want you to go
there the horse races springboard mile
there's nobody doing nothing you can do
whatever you want
not exactly the welcome I was expecting
my name's Tyson welcome to Tulsa
two grand of the week you drive for me
now
what crew runs this neighborhood no crew
up in here but in the middle of nowhere
what will it be I assume you don't have
chiante you assume correctly
[Music]
I wouldn't have pegged you because the
boy scout why not
this wasn't necessary
what is that place it's a dispensary
oh my God is he dead no he's taking a
break
this is how it's going to work I'll
protect you from The Gangs what gangs
and the law this is legal you got to
know your risk
there was no risk until you came along
ever heard of black Nick Adams
motorcycle game
you're overplaying your hand when I play
my hair you won't see it coming
any flammable liquids or firearms
in the Box
situation is not going to be
controllable for much longer
you got a pretty good appetite for
someone who was just shot at I stopped
eating every time somebody tried to hurt
me I'd be a skeleton
I want to be upfront with you
if you get hungry it's never in the
market
nah there's no such a thing there's a
one-off
or one of many
too soon to tell
[Music]
hi John Dudley you solemnly swear
[Music]
to uphold the constitution of the state
of Montana
against all enemies
and domestic
you have no friends in this building
John you're gonna have to bring your own
what you're going to do first what do
you think I'm gonna do
you're all fired
Beth you're my new Chief of Staff back
to work
I love Montana but I'm doing this for
our family we need to talk they will
fight you they will fight you dirty is
there any other way
ruin them starting with her signing this
order is a declaration of war
we're already at War I do this for my
father I don't do this for me this
[ __ ] family I love it when she gets
mad it means I'm gonna make a lot of
money
[Music]
everything
when I say we give everything to this
land
I do mean everything
[Music]
how was your Thanksgiving
that mega pie is hosting a huge winter
underland party this is gonna be one of
the best days
I've never seen this many hot shirtless
men in one place I know I'm taking
screenshots but with my brain for later
guys what are we always saying this
campus means better wi-fi a decent place
to get my eyebrows tinted no
a strip show it's a sex positive
[Applause]
[Music]
female forward
striptacular
it's also a fundraiser for climate
change we better party while we can
don't you need a lot of money oh just
forty two thousand dollars per year how
long would I have to serve in the
military to pay for this my cousin got a
bunch of money when she was hit by a
city bus do that you should sell feed
picks on the dark web stop Bella what
you've got long toes and there's a real
market for that
thought we were already an official
couple well did you ask him if she was
seeing other people uh no are you crazy
you don't ask Guys these things you ask
everyone else you know
I'm writing a piece about how short
kings are unexpected sex guys I am
flattered thank you you're not a short
King you're like a nerd Prince you're
like a straight twink straight twink is
definitely not how I see myself
[Music]
it's my turn to catch up how many girls
are you talking to 30
don't listen outside our door it's
creepy Layton's in there with two other
girls
drama
[Music]
oh hey hey
[Music]
could you keep it down yeah sorry about
that we just finished you and me both
[Music]
you think you know this world you're in
I've seen things you haven't done
you know how it feels to be powerless
to be a pawn
[Music]
in someone else's game
the things it makes you do
what does it feel like
to be a king
the city has changed the investors have
a new player
he has a major stake in this town now
Manpower
allies is not to be underestimated
Elliot's back I want them to know fear
to feel
good
powers
you don't know who this man is do you
[Music]
no one has the balls to grow against
cover
you would have the full protection of
the state
a new life
he'd be a ghost
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you understand what it took to build
this city
and you know the pain of losing it
London
[Music]
[Music]
six hours ago we received a message
[Music]
we believe this comes from the
Prometheus you think the passengers
they're still alive
[Music]
we paid good money for this trip seven
days to get to New York no detours
[Music]
thank you
oh Hellion
movie people for your own
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
out there
[Music]
was asking for the right question
you have to wake up
[Music]
Crossway
s
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
poor little Widow all alone cheating
husband
what did you do
[Music]
there's something I have to confess
I killed Steve Wood
[Music]
y
I know you think you're the reason all
our problems started but they existed
long before we met
I'm glad that we met you are the best
friend I've ever known
the best person I've ever known
each other have each other
[ __ ] me [ __ ] me so hard this button just
for show you rang can you get the
[ __ ] doctor can you please get the
[ __ ] doctor I will do my [ __ ] best
[ __ ] thank you
Toby Fleischman awoke one morning inside
the city he'd lived in all his adult
life many thoughts had crossed Toby's
mind in the hours since he was informed
that his ex-wife dropped the kids off a
full day earlier than expected
at four in the morning four in the
morning sorry I'm angry all over again
yikes dude Toby was forced to ask the
question that occurred to him nearly
every few minutes since his separation
how did I get here Todd says you don't
play tennis or golf yeah I played
basketball
I did not become a doctor to get rich
okay I did it to live a meaningful life
money doesn't buy you happiness oh Toby
horse it does what are you crazy
you've reached Rachel Fleischmann she's
still gone I'm starting to think that it
hasn't really gone on this long you know
what if something has happened to her
this is a story about everything
it's about life and marriage and how
young love can become old resentment and
money you can't get one of these for
less than 10 grand
and dissatisfaction I feel like I'm not
alive you chose this
jealousy ambition career I don't even
have time to get a divorce parenting
Nostalgia and lifelong friendship the
world is your oyster Lick It Up
[Music]
saw Rachel what
that's him
[Music]
a world of luxury right at your
fingertips sheer opulence Shia opulence
you're not working reliable I want to
promote you to General Manager
I'm afraid I cannot accept that was my
dream when I got here
but my goals have changed
I have changed
I'm going to start my own business
a strip club for women
just some kind of joke not at all I mean
do you like looking at naked dudes I
have something to tell you Paul women
get horny
Dale
I love this place you need me you need a
choreographer and I do enjoy a challenge
cuffs and collars you are a genius
it could be huge this could be Global
Russia China the whole world repeat
after me things are going incredibly
well things are going incredibly well
and I'm not gonna blow it I'm not going
to deploy it
please welcome Mr Chippendales himself
Nick denoya Chippendales is my creation
I hired him you and me stick together or
we go to war not a threat it's a promise
he's gonna walk all over you
every cent I have I've put into this
club
oh yeah oh yeah blood will spill
s
Mr banerjeeb this is the FBI
You're a murderer
I have everything I regret nothing I'm
going to burn this place to the ground
you're a bad man Mr Benji You Ain't Seen
Nothing Yet
[Music]
I'm ready
Amber
[Music]
if you're out there and you're listening
but also worried about you
did nothing wrong
we're gonna find a way out of this
I can't let it die I'm not gonna let her
die
my name is Amber chesborough and I'm
being held against my will in Venezuela
you want answers she's his wife she's my
sister we're desperate for something
you better go down there take care of
your sister we don't need money this is
a political stuff don't worry about it
brother and my husband farm and Special
Forces
we'll have these decisions are made they
want to prove a raid
we have to get around
I guess we should cancel dinner
how many lives are you willing to trade
for your sister
the CIA wants a war and you're going to
give it to them
the truth is democracy is dead in North
America we we get your influence
foreign
you don't know my family
[Music]
[Music]
Nevermore was created as a safe haven
for our children
to learn and to grow no matter who or
what they are
should we meet your new roommate are you
feeling okay you look a little pale
please excuse Wednesday she's allergic
to color oh well what happens to you
I break out into hives and then the
flesh peels off my bones
act as if I don't care if people dislike
me
[Music]
deep down
I actually enjoy it
[Music]
there's just something wrong about this
place
not just because it's School
secret societies hidden libraries
a homicidal monster
what other surprises are in store
[Music]
I'll go faster I like to travel
incognito come on let's roll
[Music]
[Applause]
Nevermore continues to be a place where
the questions far away the answers
[Music]
stop until I find the truth
[Applause]
I know the suspense is killing you
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening girls I'm Miss Thornhill I
trust Enid has given you the old
Nevermore welcome she's been smothering
me with hospitality I hope to return the
favor in her sleep
[Music]
you think you know what is real
and what is it
what is light
what is dark
no forget all you know come with me
Willow
[Music]
we're looking for the sorcerer Willow
I was told that once long ago you
defeated the forces of evil you remind
me of your mother
I thought I could prevent all this
song
my brother was abducted the world needs
you again it needs your magic follow me
[Music]
Beyond the Edge of our world
into the unknown
I need your help just like all times
running horses
true enemy is still out there
rallying the forces of evil
the only thing standing in his path is
us I'm going to enjoy this I feel
thinking what I'm thinking somebody I
love that very much take him to my tent
and make sure he's tied up I don't know
see that kind of sounds like we're on
the same page
when I was a kid I used to play up being
a sorcerer visiting strange worlds
fighting monsters
never thought I'd actually really do it
what the hell is that
trolls I'm so miffed
we have to worry
same as last time
with my friends
[Music]